[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ja Lama
ein sehr sehr beliebtes türkisches
Rezept allerdings für faule und auf die
Schnelle reart weil wir machen unser
lovers bzw Tortilla Brot heute nicht
selber sondern nehmen fertig ist und das
coole ist da könnt ihr komplett
variieren wir können das in der Protein
Variante kaufen Dinkel oder ganz normal
Weizen und ähm Geschichten das ganze mit
einer leckeren Hackfleischfüllung wie
gesagt alles auf die türkische Art und
jetzt fange ich erstmal an mein Gemüse
zu schnippeln und ich schreibe euch alle
ganz genau und Mengenangaben wie immer
hier unten in die Video Beschreibung
also einfach aufklappen screenshotten
und einkaufen gehen ganz typisch für die
türkische Küche sind die diese grünen
Peperoni und die werde ich jetzt erstmal
sehr sehr fein hacken oder schneiden und
danach nehme ich mir auch noch eine
große Zwiebel die wird auch fein gehackt
und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
setz schnappt euch eure Pfanne das ist
eigentlich ein ganz schnelles Rezept
denn jetzt braten wir alles in der
Pfanne an ich nehme jetzt Olivenöl viele
sagen mit Olivenöl nicht braten oder
nicht erhitzen das gilt für ich habe mal
ein schlechtes Olivenöl wenn ihr gutes
Olivenöl habt dann ist das kein Problem
das auch mal zu erhitzen so und da gebe
ich jetzt einmal die Zwiebeln rein
natürlich Peperoni auch mit dazu na
schon schön fein geschnippelt und gleich
Presse ich da auch noch eine
Knoblauchzehe rein ich muss sagen diese
Peperoni erinnert mich total an meine
Mama wir hatten ja das Café und da war
so unser Frühstück war so total beliebt
damals und wir haben immer Peperoni dazu
gegeben obwohl das eher so ein deutsches
Frühstück war also wir haben jetzt nicht
so auf die türkische Art ähm angeboten
sondern eher richtig Deutsch und dann
haben wir immer so ein belegtes Brötchen
mit Käse oder drauf gab es dann immer
Tomate und Peperoni deswegen erinnert
mich das richtig an meine Mama
[Musik]
so nach drei vier Minuten merkt man dass
alles so ein bisschen in sich einfällt
und so ein bisschen glasig wird und an
der Stelle geben wir unser Hackfleisch
dazu bitte jetzt nicht Tatar oder
irgendwas fettarmes nehmen wir brauchen
ganz normales Rinderfleisch
Rinderhackfleisch mit Fett dran das seht
ihr daran dass auch so ein bisschen
heller ist und an der Stelle das ganze
Krümel nicht braten und ihr könnt es
auch gerne schon würzen das mache ich
gleich das ist jetzt erstmal so ein
bisschen anbraten und dann wird sich
ganz einfach mit Salz Pfeffer
Paprikapulver edelsüß und Pulver sind
Paprika Flocken die gibt's in süß und
den Schaf wenn es scharf mit gibt gerne
scharfen mit dazu
[Musik]
also ganz ganz wichtiger Part ist
Tomatenmark hinzuzufügen das ist so es
gibt Geschmack es gibt aber auch Optik
und ihr wartet jetzt am besten noch mal
so ein paar Minuten bis richtig so das
Fett austritt und wie gesagt wenn ihr
fettarmes Hackfleisch da habt ungern
aber dann könnt ihr ein bisschen
nachhelfen in dem Nachgang einfach
Butter schmelzen lassen denn das
bedeutet ja ja und das ist so übersetzen
ist es schon das fettiges aber nicht so
negativ gemeint sondern einfach sehr
lecker und fett ist ja auch
Geschmacksträger ich gebe jetzt noch ein
bisschen heißes Wasser mit dazu und dann
ist die Masse auch schon fertig und wir
können alles Schichten jetzt nehmen wir
uns unser Tortilla Brot also einfach
Raps ihr könnt da wirklich nehmen was
ihr möchtet ich benutze das zum
Frühstück ganz gerne diese
proteintotierst also das ist keine
Routine aber es hat auch eine coole Idee
so und jetzt könnt ihr wenn ihr möchtet
ist aber kein Muss das ganze noch mal
für 10 Sekunden von beiden Seiten in
einer heißen Pfanne erwärmen und dann
zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht wir
müssen natürlich die Enden in das
leckere Fett tunken und dann Schichten
eigentlich ist es danach auch schon
fertig aber man serviert ist
traditionell noch mit Joghurt und das
zeige ich euch gleich noch so die Enten
Punkte am besten indem ihr das einmal
halbiert dann noch mal halbiert und dann
meinte schon recht groß noch mal
halbiert und dann einfach hier so rein
tun können ich habe jetzt hier meine
Grillpfanne mit den Rillen das heißt das
Fett setzt sich schön und in den Regeln
ab dann komme ich da ganz gut dran so
und dann einmal aufklappen und hier auf
eine Servierplatte stellen und jetzt wie
gesagt einfach nur das Fleisch sehr
dünnschichten und dann immer so
weitermachen bis hier oben angekommen
seid
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich nur noch Joghurt mit
Knoblauch und Salz verrührt und das
kommt einfach oben drüber und das ganze
ist jetzt schon fertig ihr könnt noch
mit Petersilie garnieren das finde ich
immer sehr schick noch ein kleiner Tipp
von mir Petersilie wie Blumen
aufbewahren also einfach in eine Vase
oder in so ein Gefäß mit Wasser und dann
so reinstecken dann halten sie nämlich
richtig richtig lange ja und dann könnt
ihr das ganze auch schon servieren
richtig lecker
[Musik]
so bei uns noch nicht angefangen also
wir drehen so ein bisschen vor werden
auch ein bisschen was während des
Ramadan Filmen aber jetzt kann ich für
euch den Test machen und ähm wenn ihr
mich jetzt fragt was würdest Du dazu
servieren also ich würde das so wie es
ist mit einem richtig schönen großen
gesunden Salat und vorab eine Suppe zum
Beispiel eine türkischen Linsensuppe
servieren und fertig und dann hat man
eigentlich schon sein ich nehme jetzt
mal alles mit dem Knoblauch zusammen
er schmeckt schon extrem saftig muss ich
sagen und das Gute ist dass die Tortilla
Brote dann auch dadurch dass sie dann so
ein bisschen einweichen so richtig schön
es harmoniert einfach sie sind da nicht
trocken sondern bleiben halt schön weich
und fürs Timing jetzt noch mal eine
kleine Info ihr braucht dafür Schichten
5-6 Minuten das heißt ihr könnt
eigentlich Hackfleisch vorbereiten und
dann gegen Abend aufwärmen und dann ist
alles also einfach nur Schicht das dort
wirklich 56 Minuten und dann seid ihr
ready und am besten schmeckt es warm ist
es gerade kalt und es schmeckt trotzdem
sehr sehr gut nur dass noch mal zur Info
auch falsch schmeckt das sehr sehr
lecker wir machen noch Fotos etc dann
kühlt das alles so ein bisschen ab und
ich würde sagen macht es unbedingt nach
ist einfach so ein schnelles Rezept und
abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos um auf
meine Mama dann Reihe in diesem Jahr wir
sind schon im 8 Jahr nicht zu verpassen
und jetzt könnt ihr noch bei so wie ich
uns gerne haben wir bestimmt noch so ein
zwei Tage offen jetzt noch eure
Vorschläge in die Kommentare
reinschreiben was muss unbedingt zu
diesjährigen Ramadan Reihe abgefilmt
werden und ich sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]